Last time.
Then we,
we talked about the candles of pride.
Uh,
we introduced the cantors who prided lat 10,
11,
12,
and the,
I was,
I was arguing that Dante comes to know and understand the virtues and vices of
pride and it's opposite humility,
which gcs featured humility.
She says featured and canceled 10 and pride,
his see punished and Canto 12.
Uh,
he got to understand the nature of this,
uh,
virtual and this and this vice by looking at the work of art so that in Canto
10,
we already have,
I sought of representation of what,
of what an aesthetic education can turn out to be what,
how do we look at art and what are we likely to learn from it.
This was the argument Dante arrives into predatory proper
in the first image that he uses to give us a sense of the dimensions of this
place is the figure of the human measure.
Uh,
he measures the world around him through the dimensions of the human figure.
And so obliquely it's not,
it's not,
uh,
quite,
we are not quite there yet to that point,
but he's wording us that indeed the issue is what is the show about pride and
about humility,
uh,
really is what is men's measure.
Uh,
we are,
he says that he was going to,
the plays is measured,
are called into the size of a human beings.
But then the question is what is the measure of human beings in a moral sense,
of course,
since pride is or [inaudible] in Italian and the Latin is a sin of um,
uh,
excessive
excessive of love of one's own excellence,
the sense that one isn't quite reduceable to what perhaps others see about us.
The idea that there will be a touch of vanity in the way we judge in view
ourselves.
The way in which we,
we measure ourselves.
Humility on the other hand is the opposite.
Uh,
is,
is the remedy to two pride.
And it is really a virtue in that it really reduces us to reminds us.
So the fact that we are earth bound,
that's the meaning of the word.
And by the way,
that's exactly how humility and the of human are connected.
They both that both derive from a common rule to common matrix in almost,
which is the Latin word for the earth.
We are,
we are called humans almost because we come out of the earth because we are,
we are made of the clay of the earth and we return to the earth.
That's the,
the,
the other implication.
On the other hand,
humility is the virtue that reminds us,
that really should not view of ourselves as all that elevated.
So these are the issues measure,
uh,
and Dante then conference some scenes of humility.
He begins with the virtues.
And that sense of humility I see are the virtue of humility are all taken from
the three histories that are interesting.
He's always placing himself at the confluence of these three strains of,
uh,
of history.
Uh,
an image from the Old Testament,
David who dances in front of the Ark.
Therefore he humiliates himself.
He tells us that he's more and less than king.
And by the way,
this phrase more and less,
this lack of precision,
uh,
is really an expression that pervades,
can't have 10,
Eh,
this is more and less.
The grief is more than I can take,
et cetera.
Uh,
peers in a variety of forms at least five times in,
in the context of this,
uh,
of the camp next to David and that image of humility from the Old Testament,
and above him actual watching down from the balcony of,
of uh,
uh,
a high tower in the royal palace.
There is his wife Mccall who looks down at David and owner.
He looks that she looks like down a Dave.
She obviously has contempt for him because in her view he is a humiliating.
He's offending violating the principle of the code where it came out to be.
She has a different understanding or is the measure of a king and the place of a
cake.
Because pride is exactly the question of place.
What place you or do I occupy in the world around me?
Am I where I think I would like to be or am I where somebody else is placing me
through his her gaze.
The second image is an image of,
but there are of the way you notice the little details,
little placed above their sculptures plays the ball off the,
the,
the normal sites so that there is an obvious reversal now and what the value of
humility can be.
That is the story of the Annunciation,
the angel Gabriel who descends literally and that dissent is a story of
humiliation or of the divine.
The divine enters a history and therefore in that sense the divine is truly
omnipotent.
There is the idea which is really something developed.
I,
I prepared it,
I mentioned it here,
but we'll come back to that.
The idea that the divine is detached from the human would make the divine less
omniscient and divine that does not know the human.
That's not no death cannot claim to be omniscience.
That's an argument that Dante users the,
so there is a store of the Angel Gabriel who comes down and the obedience of
Mary,
the Virgin Mary who says,
Yes,
I am your servant.
So there's a story of a,
and Mary is the one who said to turn the key,
uh,
between the old,
the old alliance and the new alliance.
She reverses the story of Eve.
It is a safe,
her obedience is a response to,
uh,
some kind of violation and the promise of being divine in the eating of the
tree.
The third,
uh,
examples,
story that the pilgrims he's,
uh,
looks at is the story of the emperor Trajan secular history who stops his,
from,
from marching onto his campaign into Dasia and to Romania in order to give
justice to a little widow.
The diminutives Dantes,
a little widow who has been asking for a justice before he departs Justin for
the death of her son.
This is what he,
what Dante is confronted with.
And when he was confronted with this,
we do know that he's being asked and directed by virgin to look at the whole
scene,
not to stop at one detail,
to even move beyond a virtual himself in what would appear to be a transgression
of the reverential bombed that ties them.
He,
Dante is always following as,
as disciple follows the teacher.
So he just even transgresses his place,
but that,
that CB two to have anything to do with the aesthetic education of the pilgrim
he's witnessing,
it's what he calls visible speech.
Uh,
a synesthesia.
That's what the phrase is.
Visy villa par Lara in Italian,
visible speech,
assessing dystasia that combined the cell to sensory experiences,
the eye and,
and,
and the hearing.
So speech,
uh,
because this is God's heart and God's art has also a precise meaning,
a precise meaning that Dante has no difficulty understanding or finding
delighting.
Okay.
So this is the argument at one point that in the drama of the Kantor,
uh,
some figures keep appearing and Virgil direct Dantes eyes told the people that
are appearing.
Dante does not recognize them.
He says,
I don't know what they are.
Uh,
my site is so confused.
He doesn't want to even know who they are,
what they are virtual or explain to him our human figures crawling on the huge
boulders and almost moving like on the ground,
on the,
on the earth,
like warms on the earth.
And Dante is not really capable of,
uh,
discipling them or having even sympathy with them at that point,
as you recall.
Because had I had the feeling that maybe the explanation is a little bit,
it was a little bit too,
uh,
Wrigley but Dante's poet can to moves in that way.
A little with a lot of sinew acetates that I mentioned to you,
a particular passage in chapter two,
book three,
chapter two of their confessions.
It's an extraordinary passage and that brought her in so that you can,
you can,
I want to read a little bit from,
uh,
from that,
it's a camp.
It's a passage.
It's a book where,
uh,
um,
Augustine is living in Carthage.
Uh,
you know,
this,
this and this about now at this stage is about 17,
19 has been talking about his attraction for,
um,
shows,
uh,
his attractions for the money key wins.
Uh,
uh,
the distaste for scripture that he has and how he is going to be.
It's been,
uh,
let,
let us stray by some of his friends with the stealing of gratuitous stealing of
the pear tree,
the pairs from the pear tree,
which said she doesn't understand why he would ever do that and now are he talks
about once again his experience of the theater.
They to say he's discussing his experience of himself as a spectator,
which is exactly what Dante was.
Dante,
the,
the problem then Dante and Canto can pull the tutorial is that he is at first
the spectator of works of art,
which he seems terminal difficulty understanding.
Then he has to be involved,
show some,
at least some compassion,
some self recognition with his souls through our,
this shades penitents who are under this huge,
uh,
weights that they carry and he cannot do it.
He cannot do that.
He still has to learn what grief is and what is it and how do you go on
connecting to the images that you see.
Let's see how it goes.
What are Gustin says?
Augustan um,
is that's what he says.
Stage place.
This is really chapter two or books three stage plays carried me away full of
images of my miseries and the fuel to my fire.
Why is it that men desires to be made sad?
Beholding Dofu and tragical things which had himself would by no means suffer.
The real pleasure of is going to the theater.
He claims we have a great pleasure is in the images of grief that don't really
touch us.
We had already been expected to jump on the stage to relieve the characters.
What involved in this,
in this sort of situation.
So he goes on and then you'll see what the point is,
which are himself would by no means suffer,
yet he desires as a spectator to feel sorrow at them.
And this very sorrow is his pleasure.
I was just paraphrasing that.
What is this?
But measurable madness for a main is the more effected with his actions.
There is free.
He is from such affections.
However,
when he suffers in his own person,
a uses to be styled misery,
when he compassionates others,
then it is mercy.
But what sort of compassionate is this for?
Feigned in scenic passions for the auditor is not called on to relieve,
but only to grieve and the applause,
the actor of these fictions,
they're more,
he grieves.
And if the kilometers of those persons were of old times on mere fiction be so
acted that the spectator is not moved to tears,
he goes away,
disgusted and criticizing.
But if he is to be moved to passion,
he stays in 10th and weep for joy.
This is extraordinary passage I think in the history of of Unpick,
right?
And the the criticism of the theater,
dramatic theater.
And the point is can we ever be disengaged spectators?
Yes,
we can be disengaged spectators and Augustine is criticizing this engaged back
then they believe that we can be in front of the play of the world and that
things only touch us as if in a fiction.
And yet we ourselves are not going to be able to acknowledge it.
He's really criticizing the limits of the theater,
the limits of that kind of,
of,
uh,
aesthetic experience.
I think that Dante's picking up exactly from this,
uh,
what,
what Augustan says in this chapter and he's,
he's showing how unavoidably one has to be involved.
There's not in the measure in which we think that we are not touched by somebody
else's grief.
We're really admitting the overpowered in quality of that experience.
That's his argument.
So he has learned something.
Then he has learned that there is no such a thing as a safe perspective,
the way our,
and he has learned what,
what some may call had been doing in a,
in from the high wind of her palace,
the,
she was expressing,
uh,
discussed at her how her husband,
because that offends her own sense of superiority.
And tantra says,
I may be no different from McCall in my disclaimer that I do not know and I do
not see any or any of this,
this penitents who disfigure the human form in refusing to acknowledge that they
are like me and refusing to ignore,
to have any self recognition between me and them.
So this is really the aesthetic education.
Let's see now what Dante,
Dante's aesthetic and it's ethical.
He goes on understanding that the stakes he are in,
uh,
the idea of perspective,
the idea that the world is a projection of my own wishes on that world is really
re,
uh,
reformulated.
Yeah,
I am,
uh,
if I think that I can take a safe distance because I do not want to look within
myself,
can do 11 and [inaudible] 12.
I think we'll answer that question.
So let me just go on with cancer.
12,
uh,
can't do 11.
I'm sorry.
First of all.
Uh,
and if there are questions you can interrupt me because I,
you know,
I,
I don't think this is a difficult argument,
but,
uh,
if there are questions,
interrupt me now or keep them for later.
Kent 11 begins with the penitents who now change reverse perspective are so
close to the ground,
but they are looking up.
They're looking up and they have the Lord's prayer in what is Dante's own,
a recasting of the canonical,
uh,
prayer.
Our Father,
which art in heaven,
not circumscribed by,
by the great love that has for the first works on hi.
This is the prayer of the penitents praise be thy name and power,
but every creature is this meat to give things for a sweet effluence made a
piece of the kingdom come to us for we cannot reach it to ourselves if it come
not with all our striving as dining angels make sacrifice to the of the will
singing Rosanna's so let me make of theirs.
Give us this day,
the daily manner without which he goes backward through this harsh wilderness
who most laborers to advance.
And as we forgive everyone the wrong we have suffered due the also forgive in
loving kindness and look now deserving our strengths and so on.
Uh,
the business beseeching would speed for themselves and for us for shades when
beneath the burden,
uh,
et cetera.
Uh,
the,
the what about this,
this first of all,
uh,
how is this related to what we are talking about?
The first thing is that the,
in the Lord's prayer when they change Dante makes is to emphasize that God is
not in space,
not circumscribed,
right?
God is not in space and therefore he is really,
uh,
everywhere.
He's free.
That formula he's using,
you may want to know is a traditional one in a medieval medieval thinking
whereby God,
they said to be an infinite sphere.
This is the full four mil to the fine.
What,
what the idea of the infinity of God,
an infinite sphere whose center is everywhere and whose circumference nowhere.
God is not in a place.
God doesn't have to have that perspective.
So that is indirectly,
there is a critique of perspective here or the anatomy of a perspective.
God is everywhere,
not circumscribed.
That's the first change.
The second change that he's making.
This is a neoplatonic element that he adds on to the Lord's prayer.
And then the second one is that he literally pleasers give us this day,
the daily Manna are without which he goes back with he deaf.
He literally makes the Lord's prayer the prayer of the exiles in the desert,
like the Jews in the wilderness who ask and get their manner.
So now this is,
uh,
another element that,
that another metaphorical,
uh,
elements that casts purgatory as a journey through the desert between the
bondage of Egypt and uh,
and uh,
in Jerusalem.
So the other point is that there is a reversal of perspective somehow.
Uh,
and what kind of perspective is he gaining now?
And the perspective I think is what I call a Franciscan perspective.
Maybe just explain first of all the line,
let dinette praise be thy name and power.
Really creature.
This is literally an echo of the first poem of the Talon Poetic Tradition,
a poem written by Saint Francis,
which is known as the canticle of creatures,
which is really a secret.
And,
and a four x sequence of praises,
praise be thy name,
praise be the water appraisal.
So on.
But the point of that point is that it begins with the look of human beings up
to the highest and then it ends up with the idea of humility.
We are
trans,
he says not the most important or the center,
the center of creation.
We are like everything else valuable in creation.
That's the thrust of the poem.
And the only way in which you could really understand the creation is really to
look from the bottom up and not from the top down.
This is the true that the kind of a friend respective that he is uh,
uh,
describing in the poem,
the rest of the Canto really is a connection,
uh,
between art and pride,
which are,
we're not going to be surprised since the whole of Canto 10 was a reflection on
the premises of that,
of that,
of the two metaphors are 10 pride.
So you have,
uh,
the,
the illuminators and then references on online's 92 the painters or empty glory
of human powers,
how briefly lasts the green on its top,
unless it's followed by an age of abdominals in painting.
Cima boy thought to hold the field and now jock to has the crowd cry so that the
others famous them.
And so,
and then the poets,
uh,
we look of cover Cantin Guido when it sadly,
so has the one greeter taken from the other,
the glory of our tongue and he perhaps is born.
That's,
she'll chase the one and the other from the nest meaning damp himself.
The idea of fame,
which is what the proud souls may be looking for is dismissed as,
uh,
having the inconsistency of a,
of the winds vanishing,
like the breath,
a breath of wind.
Uh,
and so this is,
uh,
this is the,
the are two moral understanding of,
uh,
of,
of pride and humility.
And in Canto 12,
I just want to show you and describe the reasons why and to explain to you the
reasons why Dante deploys a peculiar rhetorical artifice.
And I ask you to turn to around lines 25,
which is a sequence of new visions.
Dante has this times,
this images are on the ground,
so he has to look down.
It doesn't have to look up and there are images of the proud souls who have been
punished and therefore now they appear.
Now on the ground and the tech stats,
I saw him that it was created no blood or any other creature.
Of course,
you know who he is as on the side.
I saw Bria rails,
one of the giants pierced by the heavily shaft lying heavy.
I saw Tim Brailles as a palace.
And then I saw Nimrod or figures you have more or less,
uh,
seen before at the photo of his mighty work as if bewildered.
And he was looking at the people's in [inaudible],
the shared interests shared his pride and then our four tercets or Nairobi next,
also [inaudible] or [inaudible] or a Hobo harm.
And then once again,
the four more,
uh,
tercets it showed to the hard pavement,
our on it showed how he fell upon.
Now Caribou,
it showed the destruction and the crew of butchery or the turmeric is rod.
It showed her the Assyrians Freddy route after hall of furnace with a sled.
And then one final,
uh,
[inaudible],
I swear I saw Troy in Natchez and in heaps or Elian how BW abased and via the
design show,
the,
the resolve it,
this is so they're all the figurations of punished,
uh,
pride tried that has been now literally be humiliated,
but I did have to ask you to look so that you can understand the artifice.
This is what we call a visible speech.
Dante himself has been deployed.
And to do this,
I have to ask you to look at the Italian text begins with the word every tercet
with the letter v V v there.
You don't have to read the whole thing variably.
Earlier though you,
I'm sure you would like me to read a little bit of the Italian where their
caloric or for no bill Claire to the next Thursday,
the day Abria rail and next video team,
Braille there,
none brought.
And then the for next term starts with the word with the or the letter o Neah
Bay also of all the Iranian or robot arm.
And then the next four tercets with M Mostra Vancor most travel.
Could we feed this digital next most travel arena?
You got to read down.
Okay.
Uh,
most Strava coming rotten and the final,
the third set from nine 61 to 62,
very,
they are Troia.
Oh,
if you own most Strava,
which show two of recapitulate,
all of the key elements of this artifice,
we are in the presence of a so called acrostic that if you read from the top
down,
it spells the following and then recapitulates.
This is the V,
but in Italian it's also the you is to say the fall of man.
So he's doing this.
He's using this artifice that you can only understand if you read the text.
You,
if you have to hear it,
you can't quite get to it.
You know,
it was his doing two things using God's own art as a model for himself.
This is pride.
Ah,
it wouldn't seem to be pride after all.
It's excessive love of one sec silence,
but God did that in Canto 10 he's going to do the same thing.
Now with the tech,
the second thing that it shows is that the text is not a text to be just heard.
It's a text to be read.
It's a text to be looked at.
It's what we call visible speech and so what is that they're doing in he
lapsing?
Interesting of pride.
Yes,
of course,
but what he's telling us is that pride is not as him.
He is in a sense redefining the ethical language of the Middle Ages and the
ethical language of his own text.
He saying that in the measuring which you love,
what is above you that is normally sin
the same.
It is the same pride in the measuring which you do have contempt for those that
you think are below you.
So we have thanks to the world of art,
a reevaluation of the moral language.
That's the first and most important example of all of this.
The happens throughout the program in purgatory itself.
Then to see what is it you want me to say this again?
Uh,
Dante,
uh,
by imitating God's form of art as it does here with his own text.
He said his drawing attention to this is an artifice available to us thanks to
his text and it's only possible to view it the way he describes it,
describes it within the text.
He's giving a peculiar status to his own text.
This text has also its stages,
an artifice that we normally,
and he has learned from God directly,
which means that the scene of Lucifer even it's not just the same,
that he transgresses what's above him.
It's the same because he has contempt for what is below him.
So that humility and pride really have to go hand in hand and one attenuates and
changes the meaning of the other.
Um,
okay.
This is really something that in many ways,
Franciscan,
cantor,
you might want to write a paper on that on,
on the song of the so called the song of all creatures by some friends and this
particular handle and,
and say,
you may draw your own conclusions if you do not agree with what I have said.
Let's move on to
the next fuel candles.
I want to go to a bubble to chem two 16.
Um,
um,
because here we have a,
we are approaching now the center of the world of purgatory.
We are in the,
we skipped envy all together.
I will,
I will get back to that.
Uh,
and another,
and another occasion in Canto 15,
um,
but 16 and 17,
we'll talk about anger,
the sin of anger.
Uh,
the purgation of anger here in 16,
Dante meets up,
Eh,
famous,
magnanimous,
a figure called Marc Lombardo and he is a discussion about human who has a
discussion with them about the so called they show of human degradation of human
degeneracy.
Um,
it's,
uh,
the scene takes place in a kind of,
the cloud of anger,
the biblical cloud of anger,
sort of a world deprived of any light.
I kind of madness if which anger and the students that,
which violates the clarity in light of reason,
uh,
that as,
as we refer to it,
gloom of hell or night,
big raft of every planet under a barren sky,
overcast everywhere with cloud never made avail to my side so heavy or have a
staff so harsh to the sense as the smoke.
And then the language of justice.
A blind man goes behind his guide that he mailed stray or knock against what he
may injure and perhaps kill him.
So I went through the foul and bitter.
They're listening to me leader.
So he meets then in this,
within this context and this background of,
uh,
of,
cloudiness and Nia blindness near in visibility over the world around them.
They're kind of invisibility that has been carried over from this hint of envy,
which as you know,
was it's whole about,
uh,
about being blind.
Uh,
then he hears a voice and a Dante asks,
uh,
the,
the one,
one question,
the question is,
uh,
do we have,
the world is wholly baron of every virtual and line 55,
uh,
as that declares to me and pregnant and Dover spread with,
with wickedness.
But our big D to point out to me the calls that I may see it and how it's two
main for one places in the heavens and then other here below.
Is there such a thing as free,
what we call free will?
What is it,
uh,
what is freewill?
Uh,
what is the cause of all,
uh,
deeds,
other doings?
Is it in,
uh,
as the astrologist would say in the planets?
And therefore the matter of determination by forces that transcend us and on
which we have no control.
So that there was a severe limitation of,
uh,
the meaning of choices and the possibilities of choices and therefore have
merits and demerits.
If we have no choices than we can really,
we can not be praised or blamed for what we do.
Or is it within us?
And this is Marco Lombardo.
It,
it's,
it is revisit Dante's revisiting the whole story of and debate,
uh,
ancient debate about the relationship between freewill and God's fore knowledge.
If you wish that [inaudible] in the consolation of philosophy,
uh,
as is well known had been confronting he first,
he then a deep sigh line 63 and following which grief forced to alas than began
brother.
Um,
I don't have to point out to you,
this is the form of salutation in purgatory,
right?
You already had our father,
uh,
in Canto 11 with this idea that there's a human family.
We therefore a brother is that the appropriate a form of interlock fusion and
that dress among uh,
the souls and Dante,
the world is blind and I indeed that indeed.com just from it you that are living
refer every course up to the heavens alone.
Just as they moved all things with them by necessity.
If it were so free choice would be destroyed.
I think the text is very clear.
I would have to tell you that there is a distinction between choice and free
will.
There are not the same thing.
Free choice of free will.
And this is a very,
uh,
difficult tog events choice implies that we,
that it's an intellectual problem that we choose.
Uh,
thanks to what we know the will,
he said it is a difficult argument because free will implies that the will is
never in bondage and it's possible to attain the moment where we will freely.
In fact,
so many theologians worn asking that three wheel means that they will find that
can be moved by an act of choice.
That is,
it is,
it follows on the prior,
uh,
act of knowledge.
Uh,
okay.
So Dante uses the two terms.
Um,
if it were so free choice would be destroyed in you and there would be no
justice in happiness for world doing and misery for evil.
And Oh,
that's the answer that the,
the Mark Lombardi,
we'll give the heavens,
initiate your impulses.
I do not say,
oh,
but if I did,
light is given on good and evil and freewill.
And if it bear the,
the strain in the first battlings with the heavens,
then being rightly nurtured,
it conquers all to greater power and to a better nature,
you free our subject,
which in Italian it really is a,
I have to say more of an oxymoron.
Liberi line 80.
Liberi such a shitty you three subjects.
Exactly.
You are.
And you can,
you do sense the,
you understand the contradiction.
Ah,
in the two terms are this to say,
uh,
we are free,
but at the same time we're a subject I can only understand it with in terms of
what Dante,
we'll say a little bit later when he discusses,
he shifts the argument to the law saying that that's really the,
uh,
we are,
three subjects and the law is exactly that.
The metaphor for him that would make us understand what it means to be free and
subject at the same time where limitations are going to be positive.
And within those limitations we can be free.
That's the argument.
And that creates the mind in which the heavens have known in charge,
therefore,
et cetera.
And then here,
the first thing that Dante does is give a sense of creation.
He posits human freedom in the act of creation of the soul.
And this is,
look,
this is from his hand lines 85 from his hand who regards it fondly before it is
comes forth like a child at sports tier and smiling.
The little simple soul that knows nothing.
This is the famous poem for those of you who remember a little bit of Latin
Hadrian,
the Emperor Hadrian about the,
uh,
the little simple soul that goes wondering around.
And aunties were reinterpreting it as,
as not the soul that is lost in the world.
But I sold that is playing.
Uh,
the creation is a playful act.
The soul is,
it's like a child at sports,
tearful and smile.
The little simple soul that knows nothing but moved by joyful maker turns
eagerly to what delights it.
We have the idea of creation as a free and playful act.
Play in the sense of the innocence of the,
of the experience and play the sense of being three.
Now when one is at play,
when I say has all the attributes of spontaneity and freedom that go with it,
it is the basis of what I call the playful theology of Dante.
Ah,
God creates the world in an act,
in an,
in a,
in a moment of freedom.
And that freedom becomes a foundation for positing our own human freedom.
Uh,
it's,
it's because we,
we,
we were born free that therefore we can go on believing and a,
that there is such a freedom for us.
There was not an act of necessity that would be the opposite in the moment of
creation and the experience of creation.
But it's,
it's,
uh,
it's spontaneous and playful and then the can talk goes on with this
extraordinary political argument,
political legal argument.
So we talk about human freedom and not an impasse moves to political freedom.
And look at what he says,
Rome,
which made the good world used to have two sons,
which is a kind of baroque emerge,
merge.
And I'll explain that in a moment.
Why he uses this image which made plane the one way and the other that of the
world in that of God the one has quenched the other and the sword is Jordan to
the crook and the one together with the other mass per force go ill since
joined.
The one does not fear the other.
If thou does not believe me,
consider the ear of corn,
uh,
et cetera.
What is he talking about with God has um,
Rome had two sons.
Uh,
the phrase translate lion miss translates deliberately mistranslate align in
genesis where it is said that God gave mankind to luminaries the sun and the
moon,
but whereby we could really see both in the day and that night,
this little image from genesis was use dye,
the so called Eurocrats of the,
the,
the Canon lawyers of the Middle Ages to explain it as the emblem for the empire
and the church that the,
the empire of the sun having the larger light,
the eurocrats would claim was the light of the church and the moon having a
reflected light was the light of the empire.
It an argument that we'll use this,
this,
this gloss as a way of explaining the superiority of the empire over all of
this.
But we already have the church over the empire.
The empire had to take its light and its direction from the church.
Dante is deliberately violating that idea of the sun and the moon,
equating them by saying the two sons in order to convey his conviction,
that conviction that the two institutions God provides for the guidance of human
beings,
the church and the empire are equal.
His conferring on them,
any quality,
uh,
rather than a hierarchical ordering,
of the two luminaries that the,
the sun and the moon.
It's an argument that really is addressed against the,
the,
the lawyers at the,
at the University of Bologna,
ah,
uh,
where they are.
[inaudible] we're working for,
for the pope,
explaining the sense of,
uh,
the,
the superiority.
They suck the superior a status of one above,
uh,
above the other.
And,
uh,
and so with his,
a whole argument here now,
uh,
the,
which is about,
uh,
kind of legality or the questions of history's boundaries.
That's what I understand by they got to this.
You have retrospectively also some light shown on this claim of being three
subjects in Encanto,
uh,
16.
And we turn now to the very center of the divine comedy,
the center of the divine comedy,
which is clearly numerically the center 10 through 17.
And we'll see,
uh,
how,
what,
what is that Dante's discusses here and cantor 17,
uh,
the canto it's visions of anger,
um,
uh,
the,
the Canto begins with an apostrophe to the readers,
memory recall reader if ever in the mountain missed coat the for which the could
is not see,
except as moles do through the skin.
The,
the difficulty of sight,
the difficulty of seeing is,
is highlighted again how when the moist dense vapors begin to disperse the
sands,
this passes feebly through them and the imagination.
We're quickly come to see how at first I sort of saw the sun again now near its
setting.
So measuring mine with a faithful steps for my master,
I came forth from such a fog to the beam,
which were already dead on the shores bit.
Oh,
it's a twilight landscape.
We have a number of reversals and contract [inaudible],
the mall blind mall that burrows in the under the earth.
And then the Alpine scenery,
uh,
which makes vision also impossible.
Dante's evoking the heights and the lowest possible point of sight with the Mo.
Uh,
the sun is setting and the night is approaching.
It is as if the whole,
so the solidity of the world around him is vanishing,
is disappearing.
That's the experience that's,
see,
and this very moment he's appealing to the memory of the reader and the
imagination of the reader.
It is a safe that when the world outside seems to be failing us,
we have this part of this inner light,
this in the possibility of recollection of the world or imagining the world.
Okay.
Uh,
his specifying what some of the claims about the in the lights that he says we
have within us could be,
uh,
he had just said that,
but also he's preparing this extraordinary second apostrophe to the imagination.
Dante is,
we are approaching the center of the,
of the universe is poetic universe.
And Dante reminds us that this is a work of the imagination.
Why does he do this?
What is this?
What does he say about the imagination?
The first thing that he says about the image,
Oh,
imagination,
which so steels us at times from outward things that we pay no heed though.
1,000 trumpets sound above us.
Who moves the,
if the sensors of the nothing.
It's the same question have been asking earlier,
right?
Where do,
where do our,
what do our choices come from?
What do,
why do,
why do we do what we do?
Is it because,
uh,
power from the outside moves us or is there something that that is within us?
Now this question is asked in slightly different terms in terms of the
imagination and the imagination is that power that that's what he had.
And he,
he,
the way he describes it that describes it,
that removes us from the outside world has such a power.
In other words,
it's not just the imagination that translates sensory experiences into images
for the benefit of rational judgements.
You know,
this is the triadic at a strategic in order.
What is the imagination?
Is the middle ground between the senses,
the work of the perception and the work of reason,
right?
This is a triadic pattern that Dante,
uh,
could have found in Aquinas.
We in turn found it certainly in our historical,
that's the,
the way it proceeds.
Yes.
Another imagination or he's talking about now and imagination that removes us
from the outside world.
It frees us that it needs nothing of,
um,
the,
the world do perception.
It is a power that in many ways that stills us from it.
It's a power that,
um,
part of the sea describing times from the outward things that we pay no heed.
3000 trumpets sound about us.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a faculty that is completely free from the outside world.
A power that we have within us to imagine worlds that don't even exist,
to imagine things that without the solicitations of what lies,
uh,
outsiders and continues,
um,
a like moves the which takes form in the heavens either of itself or by we'll
which directs it's downwards of her impious deed.
And then he goes on describing,
uh,
three images of anger at the point in which Dante's approaching this center of
the world.
We are this,
we are,
we are witnessing,
we are shown the power of the magician is a visionary faculty as a faculty that
is not a transcription of the real world.
And one wonders why he has to make this kind of claim.
It's,
it's,
uh,
it encompasses the real world and yet something,
there's something that almost prophetic,
something that does not come from,
uh,
the contacts with the world come back to this in a moment.
I hope.
Uh,
he has three images,
then three that come down to him gratuitously.
They seem to have been descending into his mind without any,
uh,
anything that,
around him.
And then Dante goes on,
uh,
here describing the,
a low of purgatory.
What is the word or predatory?
Um,
what is the word to purgatory?
How is it construct?
There was the architecture of this world and surprisingly,
this is a like a fabric of love and architecture of love.
And it's at the very center lines,
uh,
91,
92 or 93,
that this is the actual numerical even at the center of the poem.
Not Surprising.
That's what Dante says,
neither creator,
no creature.
My son was ever without love,
either natural or of their minds.
That's a center.
What does he mean?
Natural?
The mind.
It's distinguishing here between the two types of love and in fact,
they will clarify and this is always the natural is always without error,
whatever impulse we may have,
that's impulse of love that is never,
um,
prone to,
uh,
sinfulness.
It's a natural impulse and natural desire there.
That which is a instead a sinful is the one,
the one where choice is involved.
The natural is always without the other,
my earth through a round object or through access of the fact of vigor.
So that whenever we make a choice,
we may either not love the right object or we may love it too much or we may
love it too little.
And so this is the topography of purgatory.
This Triadic Division in terms of love,
everything is a problem of love.
But then there are varieties that organizes its,
uh,
subdivisions while it is directed on the primal good and on the secondary keep
right measure.
It cannot be the cause of sinful pleasure with this work to evil,
with more,
with less concern.
This do pursues its good.
That is the creator with this creature from this that can understand that love
must be the seeding.
You have every virtue and every action deserving punishment.
Now,
since love can never turn his face from the welfare of its subject,
all things are secure from self hatred,
uh,
and uh,
and so on.
And Dante now response.
Now I will have the give thought to the other,
uh,
which pursues its good and faulty measure.
Everyone confusedly a prince,
a good in which the mind may be at rest and desires it so each strives to reach
it.
And if the love is luggage,
uh,
that draws you to see your gated,
this terrace of the jewelry pendants torments you for the four that are the good
there is,
et cetera.
So the question then will become,
and I did not ask you to read this Canto,
but I can give you in a sort of brief preview of it and that has to ask,
um,
if,
what is this love of choice?
Um,
does it depend since since I'm a have a particular perception of the world that
makes me see whatever encounter is beautiful and desirable,
where it's my fault,
he repeats the same problems that he had been grazing in Canto 15,
uh,
Dante,
we'll try to explain it in terms of love and yet we are going to be brought back
to the world of how do we perceive what it is that we love.
Uh,
the perception of what we love becomes who Huichol to,
uh,
varied responsibilities for it.
So,
um,
this is,
uh,
in,
at the central appointment,
Dante seems to be suspended between two ideas.
On the one hand,
the eye,
the notion that there is a real world where you have responsibilities for
everything that uh,
we do.
Uh,
and on the other hand,
a world where there's an imagination which is completely disengaged from the
world of reality,
uh,
and,
I can not be quite be constrained or held in.
So how are you going to suspended between these two possibilities?
How is Dante going to bring them together?
Do you see what the,
the,
the issue,
how do you,
uh,
if,
if the world of the imagination is free of this,
engaged from reality,
then how am I'm going to,
on the other hand,
going to be held accountable for what I do over the world with a world that are
made with my own deeds,
the center of the poem [inaudible] reason this contradiction,
there's not,
uh,
imagination is made to be the way to knowledge.
I can only know through the imagination.
The imagination of that depends on my perception of the world or an imagination,
which frees me completely from the world.
And then this toy ideas with the imagination really in contradiction one with
the other.
So where does the human responsibility,
um,
the poem gets nourished by this duality of the imagination.
The poem moves back and forth between one and the other.
And let me just stop here because I think I,
I may have said a little bit too much about this issues may and that will
respond to your questions.
I hope if there are some,
um,
so
please
just for now,
this is in purgatory on what products of love and he's not sure where we'll may
or may not have factored into it.
And because purgatory is the place that's in between,
it's also the place of that uncertainty.
Well,
I don't know about that.
The,
the,
the question is really are a perplexity about what I have been now what have
been saying,
uh,
in inferno,
our will is crucial and you are absolutely right.
That cannot be a sin unless there is a will involved in purgatorial.
The argument here seems to be the way I've been following it from Canto 15,
16,
17,
and the way it's going to be developed in 18 and actually frankly 19 where Dante
goes on telling you a dream.
Uh,
Dante makes the world of love.
the crucial,
um,
the,
the crucial act of our being in the world.
What do they think us to God we had related to God,
really informed in through the way of love that for the way of the heart and not
unnecessarily through some abstract metaphysical issues.
Uh,
but then the issue becomes how is this love related to,
uh,
the wheel is done,
being uncertain between the two.
What,
what is,
what is the moral,
the Dante begins in Canto 15 talking about moral responsibility is this kind of
free subjection that we have and then in the light that is available to us,
uh,
then he came to 16.
He will also talk about the,
the contracts in,
he talks about creation,
the creation of the soul,
the freedom which with which God creates and that freedom authorizes us,
becomes a sort of ground for the human human freedom.
And then in 17,
first of all he talks about an imagination which is completely free of any
contact with the world.
And then talks about this theory of love,
that rational love,
that organized the level of knowledge that organizes everything.
I could just have stopped there and show you,
okay,
this is really what the text is and maybe ask you to connect the imagination and
love that that um,
are really the two sides of Kantar 17 at the very center of the poem,
the almost to imply that we can love only and so far is,
and we can love as well as her imagination takes us to lovey.
That's clearly one of the,
the,
the images.
But clearly there is more con in uh,
in,
in that debate,
the debate is that if I love our cording well or not enough or too much,
that has to do with the way I perceive the world.
So why does he have to talk about an imagination which is so unbounded that
needs nothing of reality?
And I'm interested in this subject and I call it,
well,
I say,
this is a visionary aspect of the imagination.
It's a poet who thinks of himself as being the visionary poet and you know,
you,
you have an idea of romantic poets,
for instance,
uh,
English romantic poet who distinguish between fantasy and imagination.
Though Dante does it in terms of this imaginative power that removes me from the
world of reality,
it takes me away and opens up new spaces and,
and,
and their mind in itself.
I asked this question or from another point of view,
which I think is connected to where we have been saying here,
can Dante ever right this kind of poem by being bound to the world of reality
and to the way that which the real world is known?
Clearly the answer is no.
The only way the Dante can come to God and the vision of God is by Larry.
I agreeing with this idea yielding so rendering to the the power of the
imagination that will take him out of the real world,
right?
You cannot really write a poem like the divine comedy by following rules and
laws where they are rhetorical or where they are.
Just pure ideas of style.
You try to,
you have to go on imagining things that don't really are available to our
perceptions.
That to me is the issue.
That's how I have been moving this issue.
And I think that the poem that Dante's voice is to between these two
possibilities of the imagination and the imagination that has to accept the
world of reality and over dinner imagination.
And yet that is also another idea of the imagination,
which is so much more powerful.
But if we accept this as being truthful,
the poem it follows,
we have to ask the question of what about the moral life is the moral life then
one that [inaudible] saying that in effect or law,
uh,
the language of blame and praise,
which the pins on accepting limits and free subjection to two rules.
Uh,
is that,
is he saying that that is also,
uh,
maybe it's arbitrary that there may be some other low that he has to discover.
And I don't think that there is yet an answer here,
but that's the problem that I was trying to convey was that that's that I hadn't
seen your provisionally,
you're calm.
You're perplexities.
Okay.
Yes.
Regarding Qantas 16,
with division of anger serve beginning with division of banker,
does that serve as the polar opposite condition to love?
Why did he,
well,
uh,
the,
the question is that's the,
is the sin of anger in Canto 16?
Is that a kind of a polar opposite to love?
Why does he begin with and why does it begin with that?
That's right.
Well,
I think that anger,
I would define it as a form of madness to topic.
I know this is a kind of eclipse all of all rationality.
And so it explains why Dante,
we'll have to go on retrieving the loads of reasons,
the loss of rationality to be opposed to the kind of to that,
that,
uh,
the experience of madness in Canto and Canto 16 and we are going to cancer 17.
And he's talking about the sort of,
uh,
love,
which is very rational,
but then he is undoing it with something that stands between madness and in
love.
And that's the imagination.
See the,
the connection.
Okay.
About what you just said.
It might present a problem to the imagination.
And I'm,
I just think what I've been understanding from what you've been saying about why
imagination is because you're approaching like mystery.
So it's hard to,
um,
use the real world,
you know,
to approach this.
So it seems like,
and so you need the imagination,
I guess it's not,
is going to God,
you know,
he's approaching mystery.
So it's hard for him to talk about this language.
But isn't that more like an acknowledgement of his limitations then a
transgression?
So nothing,
it's still like fit with humility and fit.
That's an excellent point.
You do normally ask the,
I think that you,
you are clarifying some of the,
the,
the problems.
Uh,
the question is still about the,
the whole issue of the imagination that,
ah,
are yes.
So now on the one hand,
the imagination seems to be the way to so large and so,
such a force that will take Dante,
I'm paraphrasing your point.
Take down all the way to,
to see God.
And I seem to be saying that that is a kind of transgression,
but by you,
or have you emphasize that that can be an acknowledgement of human limitations.
Uh,
I call,
I call it,
um,
uh,
maybe that's true.
That's really what it is.
It's,
uh,
I call that a visionary power within him.
It may be coming to him from the outside.
He asks that question.
That's this visionary power come to me from the outside or is it something that
is within human beings?
That's the answer.
That's the question.
He doesn't answer that question at that point.
What he does say is,
well,
this is the images that came to me,
the image of Amata who committed suicide.
Uh,
the image of our has Waitrose and so on.
He goes on with his three,
three,
uh,
three images.
Uh,
he doesn't answer that directly and I think that yeah,
he wants to keep you guessing.
If this is a human transgression,
uh,
rather than,
or an acknowledgement of a human limits,
he,
I don't think that he knows yet at this point what the,
the,
uh,
unfolding of that dilemma we'll be.
He wants us to think in terms of a dilemma.
And that dilemma is at the heart of purgatory.
Um,
the dilemma between what,
what is,
what is this power,
uh,
have a power within me that without which I can never really go to God and is
this in any way a transgression?
Do I need a transgression in order to come to God?
Um,
Julissa's thought that there would be knowledge,
no knowledge without transgression.
Maybe Adam in the garden also thought that there would be no knowledge without
transcript.
That they real knowledge is to transgress.
Is Dante thinking that way?
That or maybe he's thinking that there is no transgression without at the same
time a sense of limitations that indeed that the idea of transgression depends
on some sense of limitations.
Do you see what I'm saying?
What the argument seems to me could very well be that in effect,
uh,
pride and humility are really more connected than a what we like to say.
Oh,
so you know,
we're always proud,
you know,
um,
and,
and dental trade school to me,
that's what Ken Til 10,
11 and 12 was saying,
you may not agree with that.
That pride is good in the measuring,
which I can reach out for something really high.
Yeah.
That's not bad.
What is bad is that that blinds me to something else.
It's,
I take that to be Franciscan thinking.
He,
he's invoking the,
the humblest voice of the whole,
uh,
literary tradition,
up to his time,
the canticle of creatures.
Um,
so,
but I'm glad that you are giving me the opportunity to refocus on the fact that
that dilemma between pride and humility reappears as a question of limits and
transgressions with the imagination and knowledge and with love and with love.
Of course,
Dante would say that there is such a thing of love within with laws and yet love
is one of those experiences where we usually don't like to believe that there
are limits,
right.
Um,
of,
you know,
you don't want anybody to come,
I hope to come to your door and say I love you in a very reasonable way and with
a lot of limitations.
I'm sure you,
you'll kick him in the,
it's behind this out.
Ah,
you know,
we love is one of those experiences.
Exactly like the imagination that the powers of which cmos to be transgressing
whatever limitations we want to.
We wanted to transgress the limitations that a rational,
the reasonably we want to impose on it.
This is the question of Dante is raising.
Okay,
but you cannot have you,
I think that you are your own to the right track with your,
in your paraphrasing the whole,
uh,
in your,
in your asking the question that may be transgression and limitations who really
have to be seen together.
Pride and humility will have to be Sidwell subjection and freedom will be,
They are not,
they are not terms which are,
which are so far apart from each other.
Each involves the other.
Okay.
That's what I call it.
The paradox there,
not that joins the syncs together,
uh,
is exactly that.
Is this,
am I did that confuse all of you today here?
Oh my.
Then I will confuse you next time.
Okay.
Uh,
other questions?
So we have
yes section
where he's talking about
true love and love of God is like a mirror.
It's around
10 to 15.
Yes.
Harold,
how love of God is like a mirror that
the more people,
unless he gives back and it's like a mirror that keeps reflecting and
love.
And I was wondering,
I was intrigued by the image of the mirror.
So I was hoping that you could talk a little bit about how images mirrors and
the idea of mirrors maybe are part of Dante skills.
The,
this is an online,
a 75 year old,
right?
Ah,
let me just read this part.
We'll put half the Dante is in the describing the virtual that is opposed to
envy,
mercy,
the idea of the notion of mercy and uh,
uh,
because I did from 65 because there's still setlist they mind on earthly things.
MMM.
Tell,
gather is darkness from the very light.
Huh?
That's,
that's Pato.
Va Soto reversals that we,
how light induces and generates darkness is a certain kind of light we seem to
believe or to think in terms of,
uh,
the light that is available to us,
but that does not necessarily produce more light,
but can,
can,
can them our understanding or about the way things really are infinite.
And then speakable good,
which is there are both speeds to love.
S as some beam comes to a bright body,
so much it gives of itself as it finds of odd.
So the more charity extends,
the more there's the turtle goodness increase upon it.
And the most souls that are Namor,
they are above the more that are sought to be rightly loved.
And the more love that is.
And like a mirror,
the one returns it to the other.
And if my speech do not relieve the hunger,
that shall,
thou shall see Beatrice Inn,
she will deliver the holy from this.
And every other craving strive only that's sold,
may be raised as the other two are already the five wounds which are healed by
being,
uh,
by being painful.
So the question is,
you want me to say something about the mirror,
the image of the mirror,
the,
that is being used here.
The okay are,
I think that this is a platonic emerge of the platonic image of uh,
uh,
the,
the notion that all of creation,
this is the Celesio hierarchy of the pseudo the United States.
I don't know that I have ever spoken of him.
I will those Dante mentions him in paradise.
But in the celestial hierarchy,
Dante,
the suit of the United States thing to vote creation being a kind of a location,
being a kind of a hall of mirrors where everything is reflected on a to uh,
the other,
uh,
number of,
reflections,
ah,
that all give different law that the in different ways the light of God this is
so that's where this the problem of mercy,
uh,
places are.
So there's the idea of chat.
I think Dante is interested in two things.
One,
the generative idea of charity,
charity producers,
more charity is as a kind of,
uh,
power to generate itself and multiply itself.
And the way he compares this is a,
at comparison to what I called,
but he calls him briefly the whole of mirrors.
Um,
let me just say something else about the [inaudible] when the sooner the United
States wants to mystical theology,
he wants to talk about the divine.
He will think about the divine in terms of light,
visual,
no light.
There is a reef refracted,
Eh,
reflected throughout the the orders and ranks of creation.
The highest image of this light of the divine is the son.
The son that is generous in the sense was haven't been generous in a very
peculiar says in the sense that he gives itself to all without any distinction.
And the tar depends on us whether we are going to be able to appreciate that
light or not,
but the sun is giving itself freely to haul.
This is the principle of mercy for that.
Mirrors are reproducing that light endlessly.
The whole creation is sending back this kind of light without any loss and
itself of the original light.
This is the metaphor and the metaphysics of mirror in that,
uh,
the world is therefore from the point of view of mercy and not from the point of
view of envy.
Where we do not even see the light MV is that it means that we have no knowledge
of anything that comes from the,
from the outside.
But in the world of mercy,
we have an I,
we,
we understand this generous giving of the light would come.
She comes from God and the heat that goes with it.
Uh,
that's it.
So it's,
it's,
it's a,
it's a virtual that completely offset the notion of,
uh,
um,
of Mv,
the idea God who creates without envy.
That's another way of thinking about,
about,
uh,
the generosity of God.
And that is connected to the light and to the multiplication.
So the lights for mirrors.
Okay.
Actually,
uh,
this is an image that really reappears in paradise and we'll come back to,
this candle or the Hall of Paradise organized through this,
uh,
through this,
this whole,
this infinite reflections of,
uh,
of the,
of,
of God's light.
Other questions.
Okay.
Well,
next time we'll see you [inaudible].